revenons à la lutte contre les
changements climatiques il a beaucoup
été question à québec de la conférence
de l'onu sur le climat qui se tiendra
donc à paris à la fin de l'année mais
quels seront les grands enjeux de cette
conférence chantal bonsoir encensé dans
cette conférence en principe ça devrait
être un moment charnière très important
ce qu'on veut c'est vraiment élaborer un
accord contraignant pour limiter à 2
degrés celsius la hausse des température
moyenne à la surface du globe d'ici
l'année 2005 alors qu on espère donc on
ne franchira pas ce seuil de 2 degrés
parce que les scientifiques nous ont dit
depuis le temps qu'ils étudient la
question
au delà de degrés on aura des problèmes
de sécheresse et d'inondations avec un
impact mais innove sur des populations
qui sont très souvent déjà très
vulnérable
est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que déjà
on a atteint une hausse de 0,8 degrés
celsius approximative de la température
moyenne à la surface du globe et
l'organisation météorologique mondiale
nous dit qu'on est sur une lancée vers
le haut toujours puisqu'on a eu quatorze
des quinze années les plus chaudes
depuis en mesure de température donc
depuis le début du siècle donc c'est
quand même énorme il faut savoir et donc
pour limiter les hausses en deçà de 2
degrés la recette on la connaît elle et
elle est connue et c'est compliqué à
mettre en oeuvre
oui il faut réduire les concentrations
de co2 dans l'atmosphère
on a même un chiffre on connaît le
budget mondial de carbone dont on
dispose les données ont été calculés par
les scientifiques du groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat
alors ces données là je peux vous les
présenter elles sont vraiment très
tanger très visuel on a un budget total
de 2009 1 gigatonnes de carbone ou
d'équivalent carbone qu'on peut émettre
avant d'atteindre 2 degrés ça c'est le
budget dont on dispose jusqu'à
maintenant on a à peu près de 1900
gigatonnes ont déjà été utilisés de ce
budget là ça vous donne une idée ça veut
dire son fait le calcul qu'il en reste
minime c'est très très peu surtout quand
on sait qu'à l'heure actuelle on estime
que le secteur de l'énergie aie mais à
peu près 30 giga tonnes par année
donc grosso modo echl un calcul qui est
très très conservateur ça nous laisse 30
ans les plus durs vous diront que trente
ans
beaucoup trop long et qu'il faut très
rapidement réduire les concentrations
les émissions si on veut éviter
d'atteindre ce fatidique de degrés donc
il faut vraiment agir et agir très
rapidement on connaît d'ailleurs laissé
de la terre il faut diminuer d'au moins
50% d'ici 2050 les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et ils font vraiment
atteindre par la suite très rapidement
ce qu'on appelle les émissions nettes 0
donc la neutralité en termes de carbone
la pente à remonter est donc immense
autre trempe on sait qu'à la conférence
de paris qui aura lieu à la fin de
l'année et au 31 mars y à peu près 34
états qui avaient soumis leur cible de
réduction paul canada on entendu parler
mais c'est vraiment pas suffisant des
scènes qui ont été proposées pour qu'on
atteigne l'objectif de 2 degrés à 5 ans
chaque est un peu déprimant des pistes
de solution le mode horn il 5 tout le
monde le dit depuis longtemps il faut
décarboniser nos sociétés nos économies
ça veut dire par exemple pour le canada
l'a redit nature publiait une étude tout
récemment début 2015 qui disait que dans
le cas du canada pour ce qui est du
pétrole et du gaz qui sont dans le sous
sol sont dans les cars canadel il faut
laisser 80 % la quantité d'énergie qui
est là dans le sol
donc c'est vraiment énorme en
contrepartie ça veut dire qu'il faut
développer d'autres filières comme par
exemple taxer le carbone comme on le
fait en colombie britannique développe
également d'autres filières énergétiques
est allé chercher du financement par
exemple avec un système de plafonnement
et d'échangé des droits d'émission comme
le fait le québec comme le sera bientôt
l'ontario et ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
que tout ça doit se déployer très
rapidement très efficacement parce que
le temps presse
oui le temps presse donc cette
conférence de paris au mois de novembre
mois de novembre début décembre
merci beaucoup chantal que ça c'est
intéressant